KEN HOETMER: All right.
Well, let's get started.
So welcome to the Fireside
Chat with the
Google Maps API Team.
This is a chance for you to ask
any one of us a question
that is appropriately contextual
to maps, and we'll
do our best to answer.
So just a chance for you
to interact with us.
And this session is being
recorded, so people who watch
later, it's not Livestream,
but it's being recorded.
So people on YouTube can watch
us later and hear the
questions that you ask and
our answers as well.
So before we go into questions--
and if you want to
ask a question, just start
lining up behind the
microphones--
we'll just go through and
introduce ourselves.
So my name is Ken.
I'm product manager based in
Sydney working on a number of
different Maps APIs, but
probably the largest one being
the JavaScript Maps API.
MIKE PERROW: Hi.
My name is Mike Perrow.
I'm the engineering lead for
Geo Down Under in Sydney,
which includes our Maps APIs,
Google Maps Coordinate, and
some advertising products
for Maps.
DAVID WANG: Hi, My name's
David Wang.
I'm also based in Sydney.
I'm the manager for a number of
API projects including Maps
API, Android API, iOS API,
and a few others, too.
MANO MARKS: Hi.
I'm Mano Marks.
I'm the lead developer advocate
for the Google Maps
Developer Relations Team.
JEN KOVNATS: Hi.
I'm Jen Kovnats.
I'm a product manager in Sydney
working on Google Maps
Engine APIs.
ANDREW FOSTER: Hi.
I'm Andrew Foster.
I'm the product manager for
Google's GO Mobile APIs, so on
Android and iOS.
DAVE DAY: Hi, my name's Dave
Day, and I'm the technical
lead for all the web-based Maps
APIs, so things like the
JavaScript API, Static
Maps, Geocoding, all
those sort of things.
JAMES MCGILL: Hi.
My name's James McGill, and I'm
the technical lead for the
Google Maps Engine APIs.
MANO MARKS: So if you have any
questions, please just come up
to the mics in the center,
because if you don't, we'll
all leave here.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I was just wondering if you
guys have any plans to add
support for tracking aircraft
to Maps, to the Maps APIs or
the Maps products?
KEN HOETMER: I'll
take that one.
It's a good question.
We have the Google Flight Search
products, which are
about booking.
But I don't know of any plans
offhand that I'm aware of to
start doing live tracking
of planes within that.
I think if we were to start
doing live tracking of planes,
you'd probably see it emerge
in our consumer Google Maps
applications before you'd
see it emerge in an API.
MANO MARKS: But we can't
talk about features
that we haven't released.
We're not allowed to say
anything about--
KEN HOETMER: I'm just
postulating
what would be cool.
MANO MARKS: Just postulating.
Sorry.
Just doing the thing that I
always have to do at these.
AUDIENCE: I also had
an API question.
I was wondering if there are
any plans in the future to
have some sort of route
optimization API or some sort
of thing like that
in Google Maps?
MANO MARKS: We have that.
That's in the Directions API or
in the Directions service.
You can add in a number of
waypoints and tell us to
optimize it.
In the free Maps API, you can
add up to eight waypoints,
plus your start and
end locations.
And in the Google Maps API
for Business, it's start
and end plus 23.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MANO MARKS: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm going to ask a question
somebody else asked yesterday,
and I didn't really hear
an answer to it, quite.
The person asked if there was
a negative version of
waypoints, like a
no waypoints--
places that you set as places
you want to avoid.
For example.
I want to get across
town, but I don't
want to take the highway.
MANO MARKS: Right.
We don't currently have
that in the Maps API.
AUDIENCE: I know you're not
allowed to speculate about
what you might be doing
in the future, but--
MANO MARKS: It's a great idea
and certainly, if that would
be a feature you'd be interested
in, I would
recommend adding it to
the Issue Tracker
as a Feature Request.
Because we actually spend quite
a bit of time looking
over that and are really excited
to get input about
what developers want.
So yeah, do it, and then get all
your friends to star the
issue, so then it'll
raise that.
We'll see that people are
interested in it.
AUDIENCE: There's one other one
that I put into the Issue
Tracker actually today, which
was about places, about nearby
searches for places.
I'd like to be able to do that
along a polyline, like to pass
a polyline rather than a point,
and see all the coffee
shops on the route home,
for example, or
something like that.
MANO MARKS: That's a
really good idea.
AUDIENCE: Is that--
I heard that some people have
proposed that, but I haven't
heard if it's actually
coming down or not.
KEN HOETMER: The phrase that's
often used for it is Search
Along a Route.
And at the moment, we don't
have that functionality.
But star it.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
We've seen some areas get Street
View imagery updates.
Has there been any thought put
to interfaces to see older
versions of Street
View imagery?
KEN HOETMER: That's an
interesting question.
I typically hear the question
of can I get access to older
versions in Satellite Imagery?
That's the way it's typically
answered.
At the moment, that's not
something that we're able to
offer, so I don't have anything
that I can say at
this time, no.
MANO MARKS: Although for
satellite and aerial imagery
in Google Earth, we do have
older versions, just not for
Street View.
AUDIENCE: I had one
quick question.
Can we have an API where we
combine the location and the
camera, everything put together,
so that I can take
the picture and the location
together with one API?
MANO MARKS: I'm not sure I--
AUDIENCE: It's for augmented
reality.
Supposing if I'm going
somewhere, I take a picture,
and I also want to share
my location,
together with one API.
I should be able to do that
and put my location and my
picture on the Google
Maps in the map.
Right now, I'm trying to
do it separately with
two different APIs--
the Camera API and the
Location Manager API.
But if you have an API which
does just both of them
together, then it can be a good
augmented reality app easily.
Right now, we have to do it
with multiple things.
MANO MARKS: It wouldn't be
that hard to actually
implement that.
If you take a photo on a phone
that embeds the location, you
can parse out the
Exif headers.
And then you could use that to
determine the location the
camera was at when
it was taken.
AUDIENCE: Now we use
two different APIs.
Supposing if I'm writing an app
to have a camera intent,
then I have a location manager
intent, everything.
So I have to get a location from
my Location Manager, and
then from the Camera, I have
to get my picture, and then
combine both of them together.
Instead of that, there is one
API, which is both of them.
MANO MARKS: You're talking about
on a phone, an Android.
AUDIENCE: On the API level.
If we get an API level, we'd
see Get My Location
along with the image.
If there is an option,
then it will be--
MANO MARKS: That's an
interesting idea.
AUDIENCE: It would be good
for so many other things.
MANO MARKS: That would
be one for a Feature
Request Issue Tracker.
DAVE DAY: I mean, I think
in general, one of our
philosophies is to give small
composable parts and then, as
the developer that brings all
those pieces together and
builds her application, and that
way you can mix and match
them however is the most
appropriate to your
application.
Whereas if we start bundling
them, then they start really
becoming used for only very few
specific applications, if
that makes sense.
AUDIENCE: OK.
DAVE DAY: So that's what
we found works better.
MANO MARKS: Our preference is
to not control how you use
your own data within the
experience as much as possible.
AUDIENCE: You could have
something like a fused API or
something like that, like if
you have a fused location
manager and [INAUDIBLE], which
does the cell Wi-Fi and the
GPS together, something
like that.
One more question I had.
I had once gone to another
conference where Motorola was
displaying their phones.
They said they have a barometer
to measure the pressure.
So can we have an API
to get the pressure?
That way, along with the
location, you can have the
pressure also together put?
MANO MARKS: Well, I believe on
the Android devices that are
produced by Motorola, you can
actually access that sensor.
So most Android devices don't
come with that, but I know the
Motorola Xoom did,
for instance.
And there was some really
interesting work done in
Germany by some researchers who
are able to do things like
determine elevation within
the subway system
using barometric pressure.
So certainly I think Motorola
does expose that within that.
And the Android platform gives
the ability for OEMs for phone
manufacturers to expose
additional sensors beyond the
ones that are within the
standard Android platform.
AUDIENCE: Like if you combine
the location with the
pressure, and if there is any
tsunami or anything coming, we
can know easily that way.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, you could do
things around weather and
stuff like that.
That would be interesting.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I had a couple questions about
indoor locating technology.
Do you guys have a target
accuracy level that you want
to get to consistently
when you're
locating phones indoors?
And I mean consistently.
I mean, obviously, sometimes
you'll be--
do you guys have a target
accuracy level
that you want to hit?
MANO MARKS: You mean for indoor
maps, how accurate?
We try and get as accurate
as possible.
KEN HOETMER: I think this
is a question about
the hardware, right?
So we have maps of indoor
locations, and then when you
take your phone into the indoor
location, your phone
needs to be able to find
out where it is.
And that's something that's
typically built into the
hardware that you're using,
and then would be exposed
through the kinds of services
that Android would perhaps
build on top of that, on
top of the hardware.
MANO MARKS: But for indoor, part
of that is built on the
Wi-Fi, and so that's
part of the Google
services that are done.
DAVID WANG: I can say
something here.
If you saw Waleed's talk on
Beyond the Blue Dot, they're
doing some very interesting
things with sensors, and his
mission is one centimeter
accuracy everywhere.
So one centimeter's the
target, I guess.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
MANO MARKS: [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
Not some random person.
I could just ask you.
On that one too, can you talk
about some of the-- and you
kind of alluded to with
the hardware--
any kind of hardware
enhancements, or anything
you're looking at to enhance
the indoor locating
technology?
Obviously, Bluetooth
is one of them.
Obviously, you talked about
Wi-Fi and Blue Dot today.
Are there any other ones that
you guys are looking at to
enhance that accuracy?
MIKE PERROW: I think that comes
under, a little bit, the
answer to the last question in
that I think between us on
stage, we don't have anyone
on the Android
Platform Team here.
Waleed, who gave a talk earlier
or yesterday, should
be around the conference.
If you come by the Maps booth
tomorrow, we can probably
point you in the direction of
someone who can talk a bit
more intelligently about that.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
MIKE PERROW: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I'm a little nervous
about that gong.
Is that for poor questions
or for poor answers?
MANO MARKS: I was wondering
about that, too, because that
was up here when we got here.
So I'm thinking at some
point, we vote one
of us off the island.
AUDIENCE: I've got
two questions.
The first is about
the GME API.
And I could be wrong, but I'm
under the impression that
currently, it's not possible
to create a table.
If that's true, I'm wondering if
there's a timeline of when
that might be possible?
JEN KOVNATS: Either of us.
James is the TL, I'm
the APM on that.
So that's right.
Currently, it's not possible.
What we did on this past Friday
was actually a soft
launch of the complete Google
Maps Engine API, it's SLA.
And we wanted to start with a
small feature set to begin
with, just to make sure that we
could get it out the door,
make sure it's really stable,
and get people using it.
It's sort of a logical
progression to be able to
create tables.
So it's on the roadmap, but
we don't really have a
date to give you.
AUDIENCE: OK.
JEN KOVNATS: Yeah.
And so the other thing Mano's
just whispering to me to
mention is that we have the
option now to give trial
accounts on GME.
So if you're interested in
trying out Google Maps Engine,
come by our Maps booth on the
second floor and we can give
you a trial account.
AUDIENCE: So my second question
is probably a lot
more basic, but it has to do
with kind of maybe throttling
through APIs.
I'm not sure if all Google APIs
authenticate the same way.
I'm more familiar with Fusion
tables where you've got an
application key and an OAuth
kind of option as to how to do
it, and whether throttling is
different in terms of how much
you can do, whether use one or
the other or both for the
Google Maps APIs.
Is that similar there?
DAVE DAY: So we've actually got
a pretty diverse mix of
authentication stories across
the APIs, mostly because of
the historical.
Some of our APIs are
many years old.
Eight years old is our
oldest, so it's
quite a different story.
We are looking to go
increasingly uniform, so
things like the GME API is using
what we consider the
best of our current
technology.
And that's the sort
of thing we'll be
going towards, generally.
AUDIENCE: Which is what,
specifically, for throttling?
Is it per OAuth, I guess?
DAVE DAY: Yeah, it's
an OAuth-based--
JAMES MCGILL: Yeah, so the
limits in place for the GME
API, there is a per developer
limit tied to the simple API
access key that you use when
you're accessing the API.
If you're accessing through
OAuth, the tie back to your
developer account is encoded
in the client
secrets you use for OAuth.
That's used to make sure that
in GME, because data is
centrally hosted, it's used to
make sure that one developer
isn't using up a lot
of quota against
someone else's hosting.
There's also quota limits
applied against hosting that
you configure as well, in terms
of how many requests are
allowed per day and how
much quota you have in
your account overall.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I have a question about tracking
assets with GPS.
Since the accuracy is not very
high, sometimes the points get
very far from the road.
For example, if you visualize
it in Street View, the point
gets behind a building
and is not visible.
Is there a way to project the
point back on the road via an
API, or is it possible to access
now the vector data of
the road and do something
with that?
KEN HOETMER: So potentially,
yes.
We call that feature
Snap to Road.
The idea would be that you have
a trail of crumbs coming
from a mobile device.
The mobile device is probably
on a road, but they do this.
Right?
And what you want to know is,
which road did the vehicle go
down and how far?
And then where did it
turn and what road
did it go down again?
So stay tuned for something
in that space.
I can't give you a date, but
I'll say stay tuned.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I was wondering about what kind
of data you possess in
your maps regarding, for
instance, speed limits, the
width of the road.
Say we have a bridge, how tall
it is, what kind of trucks can
go through it, and such?
KEN HOETMER: Are you referring
to the Ground Truth project
and the kind of data that we
pull out of that and pull into
the base maps?
I'm trying to--
AUDIENCE: I'm kind of wondering
about what kind of
metadata you have
for your maps.
KEN HOETMER: Right.
So unless somebody wants to jump
in and reinterpret the
question, I think what we do and
we've talked about in our
Ground Truth project is a lot of
the imagery that we collect
from Street View is actually
used by operators to make our
base maps better.
This is something
that the Google
Maps team does, generally.
And a lot of the things that
they pull out of that are
things like stop signs
and one way streets,
and names of streets.
And that's done in a hybrid
automatic, as well as there's
some operators who
look at that.
And that's one of the major
sources we use for that kind
of information and to verify
that kind of information.
MANO MARKS: So there was
actually a talk on that, the
Ground Truth talk yesterday,
which will be
on YouTube as well.
And they also talked about
things like place names.
So that's used to improve Google
Places and the Places
API, and a lot of that
sort of thing.
Yeah, it's really great.
And speed limits was
one of the ones
that they talked about.
Speed limit data turns out to
be one these ones that's
really difficult to
get canonical
sources for speed limits.
And this is kind of the only
way, I think, it can be done
is by driving all the roads
and picking up images.
KEN HOETMER: So I'll just tell
you a bit of a story about
speed limits.
I had lunch with one of the
engineers in Zurich who's
working on this, and he was
telling me how difficult it
is, because there's a difference
between posted
speed limits and actual
speed limits.
Sometimes people drive slower
than the speed limit, and
sometimes people drive faster
than the speed limit.
And sometimes that can change
between when the
speed limits change.
And so actually creating a model
of how fast vehicles
actually travel and whether or
not they're over the speed
limit or under the speed limit
is actually very, very
difficult, because it turns
out that the data is just
very, very noisy.
AUDIENCE: I was just thinking
governments, for instance,
possess usually information
about their streets and the
speed limits and such.
Can you get that information
and incorporate
them into your maps?
MANO MARKS: Governments
publish that?
Actually, it's pretty hard
to get it, but we do.
Whenever we can find open data,
we do acquire that data.
Part of the Ground Truth
project is doing that.
And it's part of why we do
encourage open data,
particularly from governments,
so not only Google but
everybody has access
to that data.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I'm coming from Hong
Kong, and I've
got a couple of questions.
First of all, is a very
hard problem.
We still do not have Google
Earth in the Hong Kong Apple
App Store--
I don't know why--
still now.
Because we [INAUDIBLE]
Google Earth as a very useful
client to the Google Earth
enterprise.
So if it's not available,
that would be a problem.
And the next question is I've
heard about a business photos
program as mentioned by
some talks before.
And I'm just wondering if the
Google Maps API, no matter if
it's Android API or the
JavaScript API, is able to
call those business photos?
I mean the Indoor Street View.
And the third question
is about the--
MANO MARKS: I'm sorry.
Hi.
I don't think I quite
understood the second question.
The first question was Google
Earth is not in the Hong Kong
App Store, which I've talked to
Peter Birch about this, and
he said that shouldn't
be true.
But I'll follow up
with him on that.
What was the second question?
AUDIENCE: The question is
whether we can, for business
photos, they take the Street
View of the shops.
But for developers,
we can call the
Street View on the roads.
So is it possible for us to call
the Street View inside a
shop to display on our
own application?
DAVE DAY: So at the moment, it
is possible in the JavaScript
API to navigate to the Indoor
Street View through just the
user interaction model.
The only piece that's really
missing there is giving you a
programmatic way to find which
places have Street View and
then landing them directly
into the [? library. ?]
But definitely, the imagery's
already available.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And so [INAUDIBLE].
And also, we have been longing
for the Mapmaker to be
available in Hong Kong, because
our customers usually
complain about some
of the map data.
So there is no news or timeline
that Mapmaker will
come to Hong Kong, so we
are looking for this.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, so we are
rolling out Mapmaker and
Ground Truth around the world.
And I can't give you a timeline
for when it will come
to Hong Kong, but
we're hopeful.
We've got Ground Truth
in 40 some countries.
Does anybody know off the
top of their heads?
Yeah, but basically
most of the world.
If you look at the Ground Truth
talk that was yesterday,
he talked a bit about
Mapmaker as well.
So definitely, our plan is to
make it as global as possible.
AUDIENCE: So here's
the last question.
In the Android API for the
indoor positioning launched
yesterday, and I find it
really accurate for the
Moscone West Center.
But for building applications
for our customers, they were
asking whether this feature
will be available in their
[? radio, ?]
because they may not have
that kind of AP density
and things like that.
So just wondering if there
is anything that we, as a
developer, can help them, like
setting up APs or anything
that we can do to help enhance
the user experience or the
accuracy on their [? radio ?]
instead of just waiting for
Google to come and
take the data?
DAVID WANG: Yeah.
So I think we'll have
to defer this to--
you know, Mano.
MANO MARKS: And yes, you can see
this in Waleed's talk as
well, but there's an app
in the App Store.
Once you've uploaded a floor
plan to Google--
and just search on Google
Floor Plan Manager, or
something like that.
Once it's been uploaded, then
you can get an app that allows
you to walk around your store or
your location, and it will
map the Wi-Fi locations.
So yeah.
You can absolutely do this.
And I think this is actually
a really great way for
developers to have business be
on a developer story, is
becoming part of the Business
Photos program, and then also
doing this indoor floor plans
and mapping to become a more
full service person, people.
And this is [INAUDIBLE], who is
one of our Google Developer
experts in Hong Kong.
So thank you, [INAUDIBLE],
for your hard work.
AUDIENCE: Thank you, Mano.
DAVID WANG: So Waleed actually
gave a talk--
I think it was yesterday--
where he showed how to use the
tool where you can do that.
And the Android API today
essentially shares the same
infrastructure.
So once that process goes
through, you should be able to
use it in your API, and it will
just magically appear.
There's nothing we need to do.
AUDIENCE: These are probably
feature requests, but in Maps,
getting transit mode directions,
is it possible to
coerce the walking portion
of your trip?
MANO MARKS: Coerce it to
be longer, you mean?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Or to be a proportion, or
some minimum value.
MANO MARKS: We don't currently
have that capability.
Yeah, you know, it's
interesting.
I remember a long time ago,
511.org had that ability where
you could set minimum and
maximum walking distances for
their transit tool.
Yeah, you might be able to fudge
it with some combination
of multiple calls and doing a
walking thing to a certain--
but yeah, there's currently
not a way to do that.
AUDIENCE: Unrelated, when you
get directions, a way to have
them transported over to your
Google Activity Report.
MANO MARKS: Your Google
Activity Report?
KEN HOETMER: I think this is
more a question about the
Google Maps consumer
application, I think.
MANO MARKS: Is that right?
KEN HOETMER: Well, if it's going
to be in your Google
Activity Report, you have to be
logged in, and it would be
you using Google Maps.
So that's a good question.
It would seem to me something
that would be appropriate for
the Activity Report.
But I don't have a good
answer for that.
As an API team, we don't
actually work on the
maps.google.com product
ourselves.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MANO MARKS: I think you were
first in the front.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I'm working on a project
similar to the Igloo upstairs.
I was wondering if there is a
way to get the equilateral
projection of a Street
View coordinate?
DAVE DAY: Are you talking about
the Google Street View,
or the ones that have been
taken on your phone?
AUDIENCE: The Google
Street View.
DAVE DAY: Not at the moment.
We have the Street View Image
API, but that comes back
pre-projected to try and give
you the right look.
And we have the client side one,
which does the projection
in the browser to make
it look right as
you're moving it around.
But we don't actually expose
any way to get to the
underlying geometry at this
stage, of the image.
AUDIENCE: Is there someone
that I can talk to
advocate for that?
DAVE DAY: Yeah, if you want
to have a chat with me
afterwards, I can try and
understand exactly what you're
trying to do and see
what's possible.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: OK, awesome.
DAVE DAY: Chris might also
be a great help, just
there next to you.
Hi, Chris.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Is there any way to embed a
sphere photo to info window?
MANO MARKS: I'm sorry.
Embed a what?
AUDIENCE: I would like to use
a sphere photo to embed to
info window.
MANO MARKS: A photo sphere
in an info window?
Are you talking about
in JavaScript or on
an Android or iPhone?
What platform are you?
AUDIENCE: Not Android.
On the PC.
MANO MARKS: On PC.
Well, Dave, you look ready.
DAVE DAY: Yes, that's
possible.
So it's a matter of taking
your photo sphere and
projecting it in a way that you
can make a custom Street
View panorama out of it.
And then it's possible to put a
Street View panorama within
an info window inside
the JavaScript API.
So it is a little bit of effort,
and you have to make
sure that your image is in the
right format, and there's a
bit of coding involved.
But it is definitely feasible.
AUDIENCE: Are you guys--
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I can answer this one, too.
I created a project called
Street Sphere, which does this
conversion.
I'll show you that afterwards,
I guess.
DAVE DAY: To elaborate on what
Chris said, he's got a project
which, once you have your photo,
then it converts it
into a Street View panorama and
makes it really easy to
put it on a web page.
So then really, your job would
be to take that panorama and
embed it how you'd like
within an info window.
AUDIENCE: So that's
street-sphere.appspot.com.
MANO MARKS: Any other
questions?
AUDIENCE: Hello.
First of all, congratulations
on WebGL Maps.
It made the keynote, so
that was spectacular.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Spectacular.
One thing that I noticed in
playing with it is you can't
look at a pole, for instance.
So you can reach the North Pole,
but you cannot go over a
pole, necessarily.
So I was curious, because I have
a very young cousin who
loves Santa Claus, and
I would love to teach
geography with this tool.
And I was curious what's
coming down the
pipe for WebGL Maps?
MANO MARKS: So the pole, you
mean in the Globe Mode?
AUDIENCE: Globe Mode, yes.
MIKE PERROW: Yeah.
I can understand why
that's the case.
There's nothing announced at
the moment, certainly.
And in current maps, this is
obviously not possible because
of the Mercado projection.
Physically, there's no way to
display that 2D in that
projection.
Globe lets us do that.
It's not implemented
at the moment.
MANO MARKS: This is actually a
problem that we had in Google
Earth as well.
And part of the problem is
that we're basically
implementing the imagery in
these strips that end up
meeting at the poles.
And so then you would see
this infinite fan
experience at the pole.
We don't have anything.
MIKE PERROW: You'll see that
we don't really have the
infinite fan effect anymore.
We've changed the way that
we do that, but the
code isn't there yet.
MANO MARKS: We're still
in preview mode.
DAVE DAY: My understanding,
part of it's the user
experience too, just to try and
make it as difficult as
possible to confuse and
get lost on the Globe.
So if you're actually keeping
the earth always within a
certain range of rotation, you
don't end up upside down and
all which ways.
But it's obviously fine
tuning that, too.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
That's something that does
happen in Google
Earth a fair amount.
People get kind of lost, because
they've gone over the
pole, and suddenly Australia's
in the north, and that doesn't
make any sense.
AUDIENCE: There is a learning
curve, I agree.
MIKE PERROW: It's also worth
pointing out that the home of
Santa is actually quite
contentious, country to country.
When I was growing up in
Scotland, I was always taught
it was in Lapland, rather
than the North Pole.
So we try not to comment on
geopolitical concerns
in general.
[LAUGHTER]
MANO MARKS: We have to be
very sensitive around
these sort of things.
AUDIENCE: Thank you very much,
and congratulations again.
MANO MARKS: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have two questions
for you guys.
One is, do you have a way to get
the longitude and latitude
from IP addresses on the server
side, because I was
looking into that, but
Google Maps didn't
have an API for that?
I was considering purchase
third party company, like
MaxMind or something.
KEN HOETMER: Yeah.
So we have an API for that.
It's called the Geolocation
API.
And it's an API that's not
freely available but you can
purchase as part of our
Enterprise Product Suite.
AUDIENCE: Oh, it's not free?
KEN HOETMER: It's not free.
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: With all these open
source things, it's not free.
Maybe you guys can have a limit
amount of requests, but
the basic version can be free.
Something to consider?
KEN HOETMER: It is something
to consider, but I can't
comment on it further
than that.
AUDIENCE: The second question
I have is, are you guys
planning to include any social
features to Google Maps, like
Foursquare, to check in and
keep track of where your
friends are, and maybe
[INAUDIBLE]
or implement something?
When I'm on the maps, I'm
driving, it's nice to just
locate where I am with the local
restaurants with reviews
and things like that.
KEN HOETMER: So I think this
is a question about the new
Google Maps, which was
announced yesterday.
And I guess I can't comment on
the roadmap, but I do know
that one of their key visions
is a personalized map, and
that the personalized map
should have the relevant
information to you that
is location-specific.
So I know that they're thinking
about those kinds of
social features, but
obviously, we don't
pre-announce anything.
So I guess you just have to
wait and see what happens.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about the indoor mapping, the
app for walking through a
building after you've uploaded
your floor plan.
So one of the things that was
brought up in the talk that I
attended was that the presence
of people messes with Wi-Fi,
and you're largely basing
your location on Wi-Fi.
So if I were going to
do a stadium-- let's
say a hockey arena--
would I be able to
upload multiple
walk-throughs, basically?
Because the stadium is going to
have a different number of
people in it depending on
whether it's empty, there's a
concert, the game's on.
In between periods, people are
getting their hot dogs and
messing with the Wi-Fi.
But most of the time,
during the game,
they're in their seats.
Does that really affect
it enough that I have
to worry about it?
Sorry.
That's about three questions.
MANO MARKS: So I think none of
us is expert enough in this,
but I think Waleed will be
probably in the Sandbox a fair
amount tomorrow, so you could
try and catch up with him.
Waleed or Sarah, who was
also in that talk.
And I will say, I think you
can re-upload location
information.
So I know they take more
than one sample.
I just don't know if that just
replaces one or the other.
The more different Wi-Fi routers
you have out there,
more Wi-Fi signals that are out
there, the better, because
we can then triangulate off of
strength, and then it reduces
the impact of people.
AUDIENCE: And you can re-upload
your data, can't you?
MANO MARKS: You can re-upload
your data, and we encourage
that, especially when
floor plans change.
So a department store, often,
they'll rearrange things.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I had a quick question
about your lat/long.
I was wondering what datum you
guys are using for that?
MANO MARKS: Sorry.
Which data we're using
for where?
AUDIENCE: Which datum?
Was it WGS84 or NAT83
for your lat/long?
MIKE PERROW: I'm pretty sure
it is WGS84, but I'm--
MANO MARKS: Yeah, WGS84
for Google Earth.
AUDIENCE: That's good.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I've got a question about, are
you able to display only one
country on the Map, or do we
have to display the whole
world on your Map?
I've got a website that's only
specific to one country, so
obviously for me, only one
country is of interest.
Thanks.
DAVE DAY: At the moment, we
don't have any features which
let you individually turn
things on and off.
And definitely, we've heard
from developers asking for
other things, like maybe, not
necessarily saying, I only
want to see this country, but
maybe, can you emphasize this
state or this building
or this road?
The only thing I could suggest
right now is bounding what
your map looks at, so if the
user tries to pan away, you
just sort of snap them
back, but that won't
always fit the bill.
MANO MARKS: Another thing you
could do is do something like
a Google Maps Engine layer using
some open data, like
natural earth data, to put some
polygons and highlight
the boundaries, and then mute
all the other ones using a
styled map.
AUDIENCE: I'm near to Android,
so I wanted to know what is
the equivalent of
Find My Friends.
The app that Apple has, do you
have anything equivalent, like
Find My Friends?
I mean, I know you can track
people indoors, but you can
track yourself.
But can I track my husband
or a friend?
[LAUGHTER]
MANO MARKS: Thor is nodding
vigorously.
Thor, did you want to answer?
Former PM of the Google Maps
API, now PM for Google+ APIs,
Thor Mitchell.
THOR MITCHELL: Wow, it
was worth me coming.
You may remember that in the
keynote yesterday, Vic
mentioned that there
are 42 new Google+
features launched yesterday.
And obviously, he didn't
talk about all of them.
One of the features that wasn't
mentioned was that
Location Sharing has now been
added to the Google+ app.
So if you open the Google+ app
today, assuming you got an
update yesterday, you look at
the menu of options on the
left hand side, one of
them is Location.
You can now define circles
that can see your current
location using the Google+
app, and that's available
across all platforms.
Thus ends the advert.
MANO MARKS: Thank you, Thor.
I think that's all the time that
we had for the Fireside
Chat, but we will hang out
probably out in the hallway
after this, if you want
to ask us any more
individualized questions.
So thank you all very
much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]